let's get right to legal analyst Ricky
cleanman and chief Washington
correspondent for us Major Garrett good
morning to both of you uh major you made
your way to New Jersey to Bedminster
yesterday you heard the president's
speech what are your takeaways the
president said near the end of his
remarks that the United States
government has waged a seven-year
campaign of psychological warfare in
this country against him
quite a statement that means that
according to the former president the
United States government has
consistently and for seven years
perpetrated a campaign to change the
world and the country's impression of
Donald Trump as if he were not informing
the country in the world who he was all
along
that is a statement that suggests that
not only is there something that he
objects to in this indictment which he
is fully entitled to
but that the government has been against
him and against him solely intentionally
illegally as part of a psyops
that is the kind of rhetoric that is
even by trumpian standards outside of
any previous Norm so Ricky that's the
political state of play what about the
legal state of play what happens next
well what we have to remember is the
political state of play
drops over and spills onto the legal
state of play the legal state of play
should be straight it should be
according to Rules of Evidence and
procedure
that's not necessarily so because of the
campaign and because of rhetoric like
major mentions what happens next in this
case is Judge Cannon is going to issue
an order and that order is Thou shalt
come to court on such and such a date
and this is your schedule
by such and such a date you will get
Discovery by another date you will file
your motions to dismiss or other motions
about evidence and on such and such a
date longer away there will be a trial
now one of the first things and I think
it's important because Nate mentioned it
one of the first things judge Cannon has
to deal with is that order about whether
or not Donald Trump can talk to
Witnesses or talk to Walt NADA Walt
naude is indicted as a co-conspirator
right they are entitled at this point in
time to have a Joint Defense which means
that they should be able to communicate
and their lawyers should be able to
communicate about the case Ricky is it
possible that he'll see jail time yes we
look at other cases that simply involve
the Espionage Act in this situation of
retention of classified documents or
documents which hinder the National
Security of the United States and Aid
our enemy days the average prison
sentence for that alone is between four
and five years here you add counts of
obstruction and false statements you
really could be seeing serious jail time
if he is convicted he's entitled to the
presumption of innocence and to Ricky's
point about all of the due process that
this defendant the former president
United States will be afforded
contradicts what he continuously says
about this process that he has no
justice that he has no rights that he
has no ability to advocate for himself
he has every ability to Advocate himself
for himself and he will be given and
afforded that ability and he can test
this evidence in court that's what the
process is about right denouncing the
process at the beginning undermines the
very process that he is being given
afforded as every defendant does and has
in this country I made sure there aren't
enough adjectives to describe this it's
surreal it's unprecedented but it seems
to not really be moving the needle with
likely Republican voters who 76 six
percent of which still say that they're
concerned with the fact that this might
be politically motivated only 12 percent
according to a CBS News poll are worried
that there might be some National
Security issues here right this is sort
of a closed rhetorical Loop that very
much benefits the former president he
got into this race early so he could say
I'm a candidate therefore I should not
be investigated why would you
investigate a candidate who's running
for office and as the former president
would he likely enter that race as the
front runner of course he would that
creates for him an impenetrable shield I
could never be investigated how dare you
I'm the political leader for the
Republican party and that is the
rhetoric that for the moment Republicans
are sympathetic too for the moment thank
you both so much for your analysis Ricky
cleeman and Major Garrett thank you